Một mại tháng mời đảng dân chú tự gió ở lời đếp kuyện bản công bố bản lạnh đạo mới
tại vì nào tòa tên đồng tiên sẽ thay trụ tệ xa này ta khai chi
khi đó, câu tụ tướng tà rồ ASO rất chức phó chụ tệ
ông Shunichi Sizi ki đảm dẫn vị chi tổng thức kỹ
còn ba Harry Potter, Harry Merat, người có nhiều đông góc trong những vực thúc đẩy vai chào phụ nữ
được bụng nhận làm chú tìc hội đồng chung
để cạnh đó ông ta khai yu ki khô bài chá xí
sẽ lãnh đảo hội đồng yên tự chính xác
và ông KG Fuller J-Fuch Chá Chí lợ bầu cử
Bây giờ chọn các ngương mặt tốt kinh nghiệm và anh hưởng trong lãnh đếp
được xem là bước đi chí lợc
giúp ba ta khai chi cùng có nền tàn quy lực
đồng thời chuẩn bị chứ việc thành lập đội các mới
sau khi bà được bà làm thủ tướng và ngày mắm thống người tới
trong thông nghiệm gửi đi sau khi nhận lời chúc mừng từ tổng thống mi đông đồng châm
và ta KG khẩn đến căm kếc tăng cửi mình nhạc mi
và túc đẩy một khu bực ăn đổ dương thái bình dương